The joe rogan experience.
So let's go back to
when the power went out,
man,
we were talking about Hicks.
Um,
you guys,
uh,
put Hicks on a,
you thanked him on a CD because
you got ahold of one of his,
uh,
cassettes and you enjoyed it and,
but you never,
you guys never actually toured together,
but you can't close to
what we planned on it.
It was basically a plan.
We were kind of setting
into motion in like mid 93,
uh,
losing our talking and
that's when it's time when,
when he came down and that was kind
of part of why he was coming down.
We're trying to figure out
what we were going to do.
Comedians and rock musicians like that.
It's a,
it's a weird combination of bobcat.
Goldthwait did a lot of,
uh,
work with Nirvana.
He opened up for them.
We have him in here and he told
some hilarious stories about the,
of just fucking Hawkin Shit
at him screaming at him
and fucking murder in their
eyes.
I'll fucking stay.
Meanwhile,
he's friends with that when
they want him to go out there.
It's like,
yeah,
like I,
I actually approached the David
Cross a couple of years ago.
Hey man,
we're going to do another shake.
No,
I would say no to.
I wouldn't want to.
Yeah,
you don't want to eat dick
in front of a rock crowd.
It's just,
it's not right it with coins and stuff.
It was all sort of weird combination.
It's like you're not providing
them what they're there to see you.
You've got attorney me might work.
I've seen guys do it and pull it
off and they can work with it.
Works with poster for,
yeah cause it's just,
it's just that the nature of that project.
Cause it's silly.
It's just a,
there's just all this
different stuff going on.
You've got film and you've got,
you've got video and you've got animation.
You've got the one too where we had
a Neil hamburger opened up for us.
That's awesome.
You know,
so that's just,
and then in the middle of our study
would come out and interrupt and go,
I forgot a joke.
And then you know,
from the audience out for a
minute and then wander off.
And when I can take my drink and my chair
and sit down and like in my spot and
take up space for western,
you know,
um,
I saw Hicks at the
comedy connection and uh,
I saw him because he was on the
Rodney Dangerfield special and,
uh,
you know,
I was a aspiring comedians.
So I went to see everybody was on the
Rodney Dangerfield special when they came
through town and Boston
was one of those pit stops.
It was like Chicago,
Boston,
you know,
there was places where people
would come through and you know,
you would guarantee that they
would be in your town eventually.
And,
uh,
Hicks went up.
He went up at the comedy connection,
or the first time I actually saw
him was at Nick's comedy stop.
And he went up after this
guy was a incredible hack.
The guy was like,
cop donut jokes,
cartoons,
smoking pot,
and make them all the most
hackneyed obvious premises.
And he was Callin audiences filled idiots.
Nobody knew who Hicks was.
Me and maybe 50 other comedians in the
back of the room at a 300 people who were
in the audience places packed
by 20 minutes in this show,
half the people have left,
you know,
I mean literally cleared out
at least 50% by the end event.
It was maybe a hundred people left and
it was a 50 audience members and 50
comedians and we,
and he didn't give a fuck.
He never came.
I,
if one joke would go wrong for me,
I would go into a tailspin.
I would,
I would go the,
I would rush my jokes.
I would say fuck too much.
I would just,
I would,
I would not have any confidence.
He's in the middle of this bit about
how Satan fugs John Davidson who don't
remember John Davidson was the host of,
that's incredible.
It was,
was the,
you know,
one of them was like the Internet
before there was the internet.
So it's the demon with his thorny cock
is fucking John Davidson in the ass.
And John Ever Davidson swells up and
the off season cause he's pregnant with
Lucifer,
his baby.
And he shits out Oprah Winfrey or,
or Geraldo Rivera,
depending on where Hicks was at.
And so Hicks's standing onstage shitting.
So he's pausing going,
I mean,
this fucking minutes,
man,
minutes of just,
just straining and people just getting
up and leaving and he looks up in the
middle of it goes.
Yup.
It's usually clear as a room
and we're just crying,
laughing.
And I got to see him bomb horribly
but yet still kill for 50 to a hundred
people.
And then I got,
I got to see him,
you know,
kill or the whole,
the whole crowd.
But what an interesting guy.
It's like he was doing something
that nobody else was doing.
I mean,
he was like,
he was injecting Noam Chomsky and know
and philosophy and Terence Mckenna.
And it was like,
like,
Whoa,
like what was,
you know,
I didn't even like when I first saw
Kennison Kinison was the first time I ever
thought I could do comedy.
I was like,
you know,
I thought saw these guys
rolling up their sleeves,
talking about,
did you ever notice?
And it was like,
wow,
I kind of get kind of could do that.
I guess I kind of could do
that if I had to do that.
But then I start Kennison and,
and you know,
fucking scream and I was married,
fuck.
And he was angry and it was
funny and I was laughing.
I was like,
well,
maybe there's a comedy for me,
maybe I can find my comedy.
Right.
And then when I saw Hicks,
I was like,
oh,
this guy just flipped the whole
fucking thing on its head.
Now it's now it's,
you know,
it's about formulating a philosophy on
life and that there is a possibility
outside of the direction that we're
going in and then it is possible for the
human beings and the,
the,
you know,
the human civilization to rise up and,
and be about love and be
about understanding and be
about intellectual curiosity
and,
and it to be free of judgment.
I was like,
this guy's a fucking comedian.
Like this is the craziest
Shit I've ever seen.
It's almost like his jokes
were an afterthought to
inject his philosophy and to
the audience.
Yes.
I think part of it.
Yeah,
absolutely.
So what,
Oh,
what I've loved,
I,
you know,
I kind like,
uh,
my,
you know,
spend a little,
I spent all the time in that
little comedy world for awhile.
It was very always very inspiring
to me to watch comedians like him.
Uh,
basically just stick to their guns and
finish their act without getting that
nervous sweat.
I mean it was always
inspiring too to see that.
And it's always my favorite comedy clubs
to go to where the ones that you end
up,
if you're sitting out front of,
uh,
the Mann's Chinese,
they give you tickets to go to
this free comedy club go then.
Because if it's a good comedian on you
can like take bets to see how quickly the
room's going to clear,
you know?
And we had,
I think I remember one time he hit
Andy kindler did a whole thing where he
brought everybody he knew down there
kind of have like a little a side,
you know sides,
seats with all the comedians that he had
a big sleeve and they did a whole like
debunking comedy and like a like a hack
hack a class and they had everybody come
up and just do like the hack thing
in front of this audience and this,
I said all these people that just kind
of one tickets from you know and got
tickets to new Manson
Sandy's and they're just,
I don't understand like that's funny.
Why?
Why is that hack?
Let's funny like,
and then you know that whole
thing went on for like an hour,
hour and a half.
I was just in the back of the room,
just peeing myself,
watching them go through this and
then some dude gets up after the meds,
their act and does everything that they
just went through and the audience is
like,
oh that's so funny.
Can I have another break?
And then David Cross gets up and then
just clears the room was awesome.
Opening line.
Just,
you know,
I saw Schindler's list the other day
and Schindler's list finally saw it.
Uh,
it's not that funny.
This whole table of people just
get up and out the door like,
and it just,
every joke that he said,
it was like we're watching.
Like he just set off a bomb there.
He just set off a bomb there,
cleared the room.
David Cross is a rarely credited,
but in my opinion of
watching it all happen,
he's the originator of the idea of
alternative comedy because I saw him do an
alternative comedy in 1988 he
was in Boston and Cambridge.
He would go up and he would do,
I remember one time it was doing this,
this uh,
exercise video where it would teach you,
teach you how to stretch.
So you've played the exercise video two
stretches that I really do feel as trach
and he was like doing this like long and
people like nervously giggling and not
showing where,
not sure where it was going and it
never went anywhere and everywhere.
But it was amusing and I felt,
I felt he was like a better version
of what I'm Andy Kaufman was doing.
Andy Kaufman would get up in front of
like colleges and like read the great
Gatsby and I was like,
well that's kind of fucked.
It's not really funny at all.
This is kind of crazy like it is now.
Yeah,
it is now.
Yeah.
It's like a delayed reaction to like
witness it as great longterm absorption.
Yeah,
but cross was d he was
funny why it was doing,
it was,
it was weird.
It was just so silly.
It was actually funny why he was doing it.
Do you like comedy?
I like music because I'm
completely unmusical.
I don't have any skill.
I don't have any talent.
I don't have,
I don't understand it.
I don't.
I see those bars that might as
well be Tibetan know Sanskrit.
I don't know what it is.
So when I see someone perform music,
when I,
when I'm in awe,
it's like,
to me it's a beautiful,
wonderful experience.
Do you feel the same way about
comedy because you don't do comedy?
Do you watch comedy and just get a like
a free sense of enjoyment that you might
not get from watching
something that you actually,
I generally enjoy more a scripted like
a film calming and when I see a group of
guys who have figured out,
not a formula,
but there's just a,
there's a rhythm to their comedy and
they've actually created a character
behind,
you know,
that actor brings something to the
table that you want to look at.
And then their timing in this scenario
where it's clearly they are just play
acting.
It's like,
hey,
we're just playing dress up,
pretend and you still laugh
because the writing solid,
but the what they bring to the
table with the writing of solid.
So like,
you know when you're seeing things
like the movie super troopers,
it's just like those guys had to have
a lot of fun making that film because
everything was just like,
the writing was perfect.
It's a quotable film.
It's like every step of the way.
It's the,
every,
every scene is quotable and
they're just having fun.
And then you see,
you know,
almost almost any will
Ferrell filling the tank.
Those guys just,
yeah.
Uh,
John C.
Reilly is like just a master.
It just bringing his thing to the table
and then making your script come alive.
Uh,
it's just a great,
that to me is like,
and I,
and I look at that and I go,
what the fuck did you do that?
I have no idea how they did that
and I have no idea how to be funny.
And just so I'm watching them just
like nail these things out of the park.
Like you could put all that script on
the paper and show it to me and I would
just go,
which I have.
Where do I start?
Like,
you know,
how is this funny?
One of my favorite all time
Comedians is Mitch Hedberg.
And One of the reasons why Mitch is one
of my favorites is cause none of his
stuff was funny on paper.
It didn't make any sense.
Like you would see.
He goes,
you know,
somebody asked me,
do I want a frozen banana?
I said,
no,
but I want a regular banana later.
So yes.
Now if you saw that on paper and be like,
why is that funny?
What the fuck is,
I might have butchered his joke.
I don't think that's good thing.
It was pretty close.
But I love that.
I love that he redefined
comedy in a certain way too,
because he made some,
first of all,
I was a heroin addict and
he had only clean comedy.
I mean his stuff was squeaky clean.
You're going to be what?
He was gang green and his leg because
he was fucking shooting in the same vein
too many times.
It was a really a strange guy.
And his material was all so odd.
And if you loved Mitch Hedberg,
it was awesome.
But like Mitch Hedberg would go on after
these guys that would like sing and
dance and do song parodies and you know,
they would close with
a rap and he would eat.